[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
nadia et bonjour bonjour merci d'être
avec nous madame la ministre vous êtes
ministre délégué chargé de la ville où
ni quand même ensemble pendant un petit
peu plus de vingt minutes pour cette
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représenté par
fabrice veysseyre redon où jean fabrice
dont je voudrais du groupe ebra les
journaux régionaux de l'est de la france
on commence avec ses 15 députés de la
république en marche qui ont écrit une
lettre à jean castex le premier ministre
disant que le gouvernement ne va pas
assez loin sur la question de l'égalité
des chances dans une interview au
journal du dimanche pierre person
exhorte le gouvernement un effort global
et massif des dispositifs sparadrap ne
suffiront pas dit-il qu'est ce que vous
leur répondez je crois que les 15
députés de la majorité sont totalement
en phase avec l'ensemble de la majorité
et du gouvernement et du président de la
république sur la question de l'égalité
des chances
le président de la république s'est
prononcé il ya quelques semaines de cela
pour lancer une grande séquence pour
l'égalité des chances il a demandé à sa
majorité et à son gouvernement de faire
des propositions très concrètes pour
favoriser l'égalité des chances parce
qu'on s'aperçoit que de toute façon nous
ne sommes pas au rendez vous sur cette
thématique mais il s'agit pas seulement
de ce gouvernement nous ne sommes pas au
rendez vous depuis maintenant des
décennies et donc il souhaite accélérer
sur ce sujet et la majorité y
participent avec des idées avec des
propositions et je préfère le débat
d'idées plutôt que pas de débat pas de
propositions qui se trompe quand il
parle du dispositif sparadrap non je
suis enfin je ne sais pas ce qu'il vise
en particulier sur le dispositif
sparadrap je pense que nous avons pris
des décisions en matière d'égalité des
chances aujourd'hui je peux je parle
notamment de ce que nous faisons pour la
politique de la ville qui sont des
mesures très fortes
quand on dédouble les classes en cp au
ce1 je ne pense pas que ce soit des
mesures sparadrap quand nous plaçons des
des quartiers en reconquête républicaine
en mettant plus de forces de police sur
le terrain pour assurer la sécurité et
la sérénité de nos concitoyens je ne
pense pas que ce soit des mesures
sparadrap et encore vendredi les deux il
ya quelques fins de semaine monsieur le
premier ministre jean castex annonce 3 3
milliards en relève
vers les quartiers donc là aussi je ne
pense pas que ce soit des mesures
sparadrap parmi les mesures dont il
appelle à la mise en oeuvre il ya une
promesse présidentielle c'est le revenu
universel d'activité ils appellent à une
relance d'urgence de ce dispositif est
ce que vous allez faire
il y a eu enfin des neely a eu une
grande des groupes de travail qui avait
été créé déjà il ya quelques en début de
quinquennat pour avancer sur ce sujet je
tiens à rappeler qu'il s'agit aussi
d'une promesse de campagne de coupe donc
du président de la république et qu'il
faut maintenant effectivement commencé à
avancer sur ce sujet parce que c'est
réalisable en ces temps de crise je
justement la crise a eu pour effet de
ralentir un certain nombre de sujets
parce que l'urgence il faut gérer
l'urgence de la crise sanitaire il faut
jurer d'urgence de la crise économique
et sociale mais en tout cas il y a une
chose qui n'est pas remise en cause
c'est notre détermination à avancer sur
la transformation aujourd'hui de notre
pays
le revenu universel d'activité en études
donc il faut effectivement accélérer la
réflexion sur ce sujet alors il ya des
mesures qui sont présentés on va en
parler notamment ces trois milliards
mais le grand plan égalité des chances
qui était annoncé on va le voir quand
alors la première le comité
interministériel des villes est un est
une première brique de cette grande
séquence d'égalité des chances et il a
vocation ce cette séquence en tout cas
pour l'égalité des chances a vocation à
perdurer sur quelques quelques semaines
quelques mois parce que justement les
propositions aujourd'hui sont sur la
table et nous avançons sur un certain
nombre de sujets évidemment matière
d'éducation d'emploi de logement de
cadre merveilleux mesure qui sera
annoncé qu'ils sont annoncés au fur et à
me
il y aura de grands discours d' emmanuel
macron sur l'égalité des chances je ne
sais pas s'il compte faire un grand
discours en tout cas tout ce que je peux
vous assurer c'est que tout le monde est
au travail pour cela et et que le
président de la république annoncera des
choses et des mesures qui soient
vraiment concrètes
c'est ce que nous avons toujours fait
depuis trois ans et c'est ce que nous
continuerons à faire est-ce que vous
travaillez à de nouvelles mesures
sociales précisément mais je pense qu'il
faut jamais arrêter la réflexion parce
que il faut s'adapter aussi aux nouveaux
paramètres que nous avons et qui change
et qui ont changé
certes cette dernière année avec cette
crise sociale face à cette crise
sanitaire qui a débouché sur une crise
économique et sociale
donc la réflexion ne doit jamais
s'arrêter il y à des mesures
effectivement que sur lesquels nous
avons travaillé moi pour ma part j'ai
longtemps enfin j'ai travaillé pendant
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois à la
concertation avec les élus le milieu
associatif
les habitants eux mêmes pour que nous
puissions construire des mesures qui
nous semble efficace en fonction des
priorités qui nous ont été aussi livrés
pendant ces dernières semaines et donc
j'espère bien qu'avec les annonces que
nous avons fait avec ce comité
interministériel des villes nous
pourrons répondre en tout cas un certain
nombre de sujets de problématiques de
difficultés sur les terres à d'autres
sur le plan social que celles qui ont
déjà été annoncés leur disque activement
d'autres d'autres annonces dans l'est
dans les semaines et mois à venir sur
quels sujets notamment sur le logement
social sur le las que là il ya des
semaines supplémentaires qu'il y ait des
réflexions
oui il ya des correctifs à apporter sur
la question justement des attributions
de logements parce que nous voulons
aller très loin sur la question de la
mixité sociale
il y a effectivement tout ce que nous
pouvons faire à travers la construction
de l'offre de logement mais il ya aussi
tout ce que nous pouvons faire à travers
la politique d'attribution de logements
des logements sociaux donc oui nous
sommes au travail sur cette question et
plus précisément que quand vous dites il
faut qu'on travaille sur la mixité
sociale plus continuellement ça veut
dire comme ça veut dire que alors en
skins en ce qui me concerne dans le
ministère de la ville nous avons un
outil qui s'appelle agence nationale de
la rénovation urbaine qui justement à
travers les propos les projets de
renouvellement urbain a comme objectif
d'atteindre cette mixité sociale c'est à
dire que dans certains territoires là où
il y a trop de logements sociaux il ya
l'objectif c'est de diminuer cette part
de logements sociaux pour soi
diversifier l'offre de logement social
soit diminué de manière très conséquente
là où il ya une concentration de la
pauvreté et inversement sur les communes
qui ne respectent pas les obligations de
la loi sru qui impose des quotas de
logements sociaux est ce que là il va y
avoir des mesures qui vont être prises
alors il y a déjà des renforcement des
sanctions de la loi sru en tout cas nous
avons demandé à ce qu'il y ait une
application très stricte des sanctions
qui sont liées à la loi sru et donc qui
impose les communes à avoir un taux de
logements sociaux de 25% et avec le
comité interministériel des villes ce
que nous avons voulu faire s'est fixé
aussi un plafond
c'est à dire que les communes qui
détiennent déjà plus de 40 % de
logements sociaux mais nous visons
vraiment particulièrement les communes
qui concentre de la pauvreté et là où il
ya du logement très social est bien
celle ci nous demandons au préfet
d'avoir d'encadrer la construction de
logements très sociaux pour ne laisser
effectivement que place qu'à la
diversification de l'offre ou au
développement de la construction de
logements mixtes pour la pleine
compréhension de nos téléspectateurs ce
que vous avez aussi un collègue qui est
en charge de la ruralité au gouvernement
à partir de quel moment vous considérer
qu'une commune et qu'une ville vous dans
votre portefeuille
alors moi je m'occupe de de toutes les
villes qui ont des quartiers politique
de la ville donc ça représente 850 6
communes aujourd'hui sur territoire
français 1514 quartier politique de la
ville donc mais la réalité c'est que
quand on agit sur un quartier politique
de la ville à l'échelle d'une ville on
agit aussi allégée à l'échelle du
territoire parce que la communauté la
communauté d'agglomération où l'on ne
peut pas se désintéresser de ce qui se
passe dans la ville qui détient des
quartiers politique de la ville
et dans des départements ou dans des
régions qui en consomme concentre aussi
beaucoup et bien c'est là c'est tous les
acteurs à tous les niveaux qui doivent
agir également
alors vous me l'avez dit jean castex a
annoncé une enveloppe de plus de 3
milliards d'euros c'était lors du comité
interministériel de la ville ces trois
milliards d'euros précisément ils vont
être fléché vers où ils vont financer
quoi alors ils vont être il y a des
priorités notamment le logement parce
qu'on vient d'en parler mais on a on va
abonder les crédits de l'anru 2
milliards supplémentaires pour porter
l'enveloppent à 12 milliards de crédits
pour l'anru et quand j'entends certains
responsables politiques ou ou même de la
société civile qui font le procès de
dire qu'on met trop d'argent dans l'anru
qu'on a trop déversés sur la rénovation
urbaine
je les invite vraiment allait venir avec
moi sur le terrain et s'apercevoir de
l'insalubrité dans laquelle vivent
certains de nos concitoyens
j'étais encore au chêne pointu le
quartier du chêne pointu à
clichy-sous-bois vendredi ben je peux
vous dire que la rénovation urbaine là
bas c'est pas un concept c'est une
réalité
c'est attendu pour améliorer le cadre de
vie des habitants donc ça c'est une
mesure effectivement très forte pour
aller très loin dans la question du
renouvellement urbain
l'amélioration du bâti la construction
aussi de logements sociaux
mais c'est aussi la rénovation des
écoles des équipements sportifs donc et
l'amélioration du cadre de vie donc avec
l'installation de l'environnement tels
que les fermes urbaines où les jardins
partagés qui permette vraiment
d'apporter une amélioration dans le
cadre de vie familiale d'autres on parle
de rénovation urbaine quand vous étiez
sur ce plateau vous nous avez dit que 85
% du plan borloo était engagé est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous désiriez encore ça
ou est ce que vous dites je me suis
peut-être un peu de compassion
maintenant moi je me trompe pas sûr je
me suis pas trompé sur les chiffres 3
85% de la feuille de route du
gouvernement a été engagée dans cette
feuille de route nous avons pris 15 des
19 propositions du rapport borloo qui
sont aujourd'hui en cours de 2
fait bondir certains et mais fragile oui
ils peuvent ils peuvent rebondir mais
vous savez le rapport borloo enfin g j
ai travaillé j'ai participé aux ateliers
avec l'ensemble des élus de milieux
associatifs pour donner lieu à ce
rapport la réalité des choses c'est que
on a un contexte aujourd'hui en france
qui a littéralement changé par rapport à
il ya trois ans nous ne pouvons plus
avoir la même les mêmes réflexes ou les
mêmes idéaux propositions sans tenir
compte de ce qui s'est passé de ce que
nous vivons depuis maintenant un an et
l'état
la situation de notre pays donc oui 15
des 19 propositions du rapport borloo
sont engagées par le gouvernement
mais je tiens juste à rappeler qu'il ya
eu d'autres concertation entre temps
qu'il ya eu d'autres rapports qui ont
été aussi émis entre temps et quand
j'entends les élus nous demander des
quartiers de reconquête républicaine
quand on y salue le dédoublement des
classes je suis désolé ce ne sont pas
des mesures du rapport borloo donc on a
le droit effectivement de se servir de
ce rapport pour alimenter notre
réflexion et conduire nos politiques
publiques comme nous avons le droit de
nous en détacher et d'avoir d'autres
d'autres réflexions ça a été le cas pour
la préparation de ce comité
interministériel des villes et les
annonces qui en ont découlé
c'est pas juste un chiffre comme ça
qu'on lance 3 milliards 300 millions
ce sont des mesures extrêmement
concrètes objective et est financé ce
qui est très nouveau pour les élus
locaux et qui sont les premiers à être
satisfaits du résultat de ce comité
interministériel dont il peut pas
raisonner comme il ya trois ans mais
vous dites aussi que le nombre d'actes
de violence s'ils n'augmentent pas dans
ces quartiers en revanche le degré lui a
augmenté il y à une urgence le dessus
oui mais complètement il ya une une
grande urgence parce que je dis toujours
que les premières victimes de
l'insécurité sont les habitants des
quartiers ceux qui vivent les trafics
c'est ce qu'ils habitent quand vous
montez vous prenez des escaliers que
vous ne pouvez pas accéder à votre
appartement parce que les trafics se
font là où quand l'ascenseur est
dégradée parce que justement les
trafiquants dégradé l'ascenseur pour
qu'ils aient pas de flux des habitants
ce sont les premières victimes de
l'insécurité dans nos quartiers donc moi
je suis extrêmement attachée à la
question de la sécurité est aujourd'hui
c'est ce que nous faisons avec le
déploiement des quartiers de reconquête
républicaine je rappelle
280 effectifs supplémentaires
représentait fin dans sept quartiers de
reconquête républicaine est une mesure
extrêmement concrètes qui a été annoncé
par le premier ministre à l'issue du
comité interministériel des villes qui
viendra renforcer les 55 quartier de
reconquête républicaine c'est plus de
1200 forces de police supplémentaires
dans nos quartiers ça c'est du concret
ça c'est pour vous avez réussi à
apporter de la sérénité de la sécurité
ce soit des enseignants les policiers
vous arrivez à recruter oui enfin la
formation de des forces de l'ordre elle
est il ya oui on arrive à recruter là où
on arrive enfin on arrive à recruter
ensuite l'heure je pense notamment aux
enseignants quand leur première
affectation est un quartier politique de
la ville et particulièrement là où c'est
difficile on peut comprendre une
certaine appréhension pour aborder ce
poste-là mais quand je vais à la
rencontre des enseignants vous avez ceux
effectivement qui parfois sont en
difficulté vivent peut-être un peu plus
difficilement la situation à laquelle
ils sont confrontés puis vous en avez
d'autres qui sont parfaitement engagé et
qui ne se voit pas ailleurs
donc je pense que là la question
vraiment encore une fois de la sécurité
nous y sommes extrêmement attachés
nous renforçons les moyens pour cela je
rappelle juste que pour les enseignants
qui enseigne en dirai plus il ya une
prime pour récompenser en tout cas pour
encourager effectivement leur travail au
quotidien parce que il faut pas voir
l'enseignement dans des quartiers juste
sous l'angle sécuritaire ou parfois
effectivement il peut ya des dérives
il faut le voir aussi sous l'angle des
difficultés sociales auxquelles sont
confrontés les enseignants fce qui se
l'est prennent aussi en pleine figure si
je peux me permettre cette expression
est bien là aussi il s'agit les
encourager d'être à leurs côtés
justement puisqu'on parle des
enseignants parlant de l'éducation des
sites et éducatives y en a 80 à l'heure
actuelle le gouvernement vise 2
d'ici 2022 il ya des mères dont
catherine arnaud cayla maire de
chanteloup les vignes qui dit qu'à ce
rythme on y sera encore en 2038 elle a
dit qu'il en faudrait 100 nouvelles par
an qu'est ce que vous dites ça va pas
assez vite
déjà je catherine arin arin où est la
première à féliciter ce dispositif est
d'ailleurs je tiens juste à rappeler à
leurs demandes plus du coup elle
oui et puis elles bénéficient d'un
accompagnement extrêmement important de
l'état dans le cadre de sa cité
éducative et d'ailleurs nous intervenons
une nouvelle fois chanteloup les vignes
pour traduire sa cité éducative en
immobilier donc là où les crédits du
plan de relance seront mobilisés pour
aider catherine arenou dans cette danse
est dans ce projet est donc laissée
éducatif faut déjà bien comprendre et
bien saisir ce que c'est on agit dans
des territoires où c'est compliqué parce
qu'ils adhéraient prêt plus où ce sont
des quartiers de reconquête républicaine
où il y à des opérations de de l'anru
donc ce sont des territoires extrêmement
ciblés dans lequel nous apportons un
financement de l'état
effectivement c'est important c'est pour
ça que les collectivités d'ailleurs
candidate très elles sont très
nombreuses à candidater mais c'est
surtout un projet éducatif est un projet
de territoire
donc on peut pas aller venir comme ça et
de se dire on va aller démultiplier les
sites éducatifs partout tout le temps
tout de suite et on va couvrir les 1500
quartier en tant d'années c'est pas
comme ça que ça se passe
ça se reposent en fait on se repose sur
des acteurs de territoire qui doivent
travailler le projet de territoire et
dans certains territoires il n'existe
pas justement ce projet éducatif
donc il faut d'abord aider à construire
et à préparer le terrain en soutenant
les associations en soutenant les
collectivités comme nous faisons
aujourd'hui
mais la cité éducative il faut bien
comprendre que c'est une méthode de
travail qui part du terrain et qui fait
pour le terrain et donc on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui se fixer des objectifs en se
disant on va couvrir tous les quartiers
at elle à telle date par contre nous
savons que effectivement par rapport à
tous les dossiers qui nous sont remontés
que 200 d'ici 2022 c'est atteignable et
c'est pour ça que nous l'avons annoncé
non ça serait donc c'est si vous nous
dites
ces 3 3 milliards ce ne sont pas que des
chiffres ça correspond à des projets
concrets comment vous allez vous assurer
que les financements iront au bon
endroit qu'ils seront fléchés au bon
endroit que les crédits arriveront vite
surtout mais ça c'est une excellente
question parce que je l'appelle du 14
novembre à des qit veulent savoir
voilà comment il va se passer quoi
exactement à 17 h alors depuis le 14
novembre il s'est passé beaucoup de
choses
et sur le plan de relance il a posé la
glisse france et 3 milliards comment
vous travaillez avec l'école et
justement on va travailler comme on a
fait pour depuis le 14 novembre pour le
plan de relance c'est à dire qu'on a
demandé au préfet dans d'animer des
comités territoriaux et donc sur les
départements il y à des comités qui ont
déjà et se sont déjà organisés
j'ai présidé une réunion qui est qui a
été organisée par le sous préfet ville
dans le rhône dont le département du
rhône où là il l'a fait appel à tous les
opérateurs de l'état c'est comme ça que
ça va se passer pour les 3 milliards ont
fait appel à tous les opérateurs de
l'état local
les services de l'état local évidemment
c'est eux qui organise ce type de rhinau
qui l'animent
mais également tous les élus quartier
politique de la ville les acteurs clés
des donc des associés du milieu
associatif seront réunis pour justement
réalisé concrètement la traduction de
ces mesures
aujourd'hui il ne s'agit plus je crois
de faire des annonces comme ça en disant
on va annoncer tant de milliards on va
faire tant de temps de deux quartiers de
reconquête républicaine temps on va
aller s'assurer que les mesures se
traduisent très concrètement dans les
faits mais en impliquant l'ensemble des
acteurs est chargé de ça ce sont les
préfets qui seront ceux chargés de
réunir ces comités explique sa surface
et doit vous rendre des comptes
régulièrement comment elle va
s'organiser
nous venons vous vous allez vérifier que
ça marche effectivement sur le terrain
alors je verrai justement donc je vais
réagir et vérifier sur le terrain que ça
marche donc j'irai assisté à certains
comités territoriaux et et oui moi les
filets préfet à l'égalité des chances
je les réunis tous les quinze jours donc
lui rend le l'état des lieux nous le
ferons évidemment au fur et à mesure et
je mange en assurait que ces mesures
arrivent très concrètement et d'ailleurs
c'est déjà le cas dans le plan de
relance je m'étais engagé à aller sur le
terrain voir concrètement ce milliard
d'euros qui a été fléchés vers les
quartiers politique de la ville qui
trouve très concrètement sa place eh
bien je mathieu jeu
vraiment je constate avec beaucoup de
satisfaction que ça se traduit très
concrètement dans les faits à chanteloup
les i à grigny à roubaix et à d'autres
communes encore dans le cas de ce
dispositif de cette collaboration est en
collectivité qu'est ce que vous attendez
des élus locaux
nous attendons donc qu'ils soient les
élus locaux vous savez ce sont les
porteurs de projets en local ce n'est
pas nous qui allons décider de savoir
qu'est ce qui est meilleur pour la ville
en terme de subsides en termes
d'accompagnement alors en termes
d'accompagnement ils ont à plusieurs on
a mis plusieurs outils à leur
disposition
d'abord ces comités départementaux
ensuite nous avons créé un guide pour
l'élu local
un guide qui peut trouver sur le site
donc sur france relance ou même sur le
site de du ministère de la cohésion des
territoires
un guide qui a été créé avec jacqueline
gourault et et bruno le maire ou mon
ministère et j'ai été donc grandement
associés pour aller informer les élus
locaux de la façon dont il pouvait se
saisir du plan de relance et quand je le
remets aux élus locaux j'ai eu
l'occasion de le remettre directement à
philippe riou maire de grigny ou même à
catherine arenou directement à
chanteloup les vignes et bien le retour
c'est que si moi j'ai pu le lire
tout le monde peut le dire tout le monde
peut le comprendre donc votre guide est
vraiment très intéressant très important
et surtout il sera extrêmement utile
pour l'accompagnement des projets et
ensuite nous travaillons avec l'agencé
nationale de la cohésion des territoires
pour mettre à disposition là aussi des
de l'ingénierie locales pour accompagner
les élus locaux dans le portage de leurs
projets mais encore une fois
les mesures que nous annonçons nous nous
allons nous assurer que tous les outils
que tous les acteurs de l'état sont
mobilisés pour cela c'est ça revient de
la responsabilité des élus de s'en
emparer
une question d'actualité à la ministre
mais aussi à l'élu de trappes que vous
êtes savez que depuis novembre un prof
de philo va enseigner sous protection
policière dans la ville de trappes
tout ça parce qu'il a défendu les
principes républicains il a défendu sa
mais elle pâtit il a témoigné d'un
phénomène je cite d'emprise islamistes
ils dénoncent le manque de stratégie de
l'état face à l'islam politique et il
dit je considère que trap est une ville
définitivement perdu qu'est ce que vous
dites alors déjà je veux condamner de
manière la plus ferme
s'il ya des menaces bien toutes les
menaces dont est victime
monsieur le maire a tranché le maire
exactement je le condamne fermement et
j'espère que les auteurs seront
condamnés pour pour cela je tiens aussi
à rappeler qu'il dispose de protections
je m'en suis assuré ce week end et la
sphère est prise très sérieusement de la
fin de la procureure la rectrice et du
private en troisième avec lui et avec
les services de l'état local donc c'est
intolérable et ça n'a pas sa place dans
la république
donc oui nous nous y attelons à
l'islamisme définitivement non
alors par contre tu rappes n'est pas
définitivement perdue parce que je
refuse encore une fois de manière la
plus ferme toutes les toutes les menaces
dont est victime ce professeur et la
droite toute la protection de la
république mais je refuse qu'on jette
l'opprobre sur trente deux mille
habitants
je suis désolé je connais bien cette
ville oui il y à des groupuscules
islamistes c'est la vérité c'est un fait
il faut pas le nier et nous nous y à
dire beaucoup d'enfants sont élevées
dans la haine de la france
elle n'aura pas beaucoup de temps avant
que ça dlr ensuite donc je lui il ya des
groupuscules et oui nous nous attelons à
les démanteler 1-1 et louis avec le
projet de loi qui conforte les princes
et les principes de la république qui
est en discussion au parlement
nous allons également apporter des
solutions extrêmement concrètes je pense
notamment à l'engagement de contrat
républicain
je pense nous gagnent également à tout
ce qui est pression des séparatistes
nous y répondons à travers le projet
doit ensuite c'est tout ce que nous
faisons par la loi et par l'aspect
sécuritaire mais il ya tout le reste
qu'il faut aussi comblé parce que il
faut pas oublier que les séparatistes
ils font leurs idées leurs ni sur quoi
il faut leur lit sur ce sentiment
d'abandon et de rejet cas là parfois la
république que cette l'impression que la
république n'a pas rempli ses promesses
et qu'il y à une inégalité de traitement
et une inégalité de résultats dans ces
quartiers par rapport au reste du zaire
atterri que le temps de ce que l'état
ait déserté mais vous savez dans
certains territoires c'est vrai quand
vous avez un recul des services publics
quand vous avez des élus qui ne
financent pas des associations et bien
c'est pour moi c'est l'état qui reculent
et quand d'état qui recule vous avez
l'offre alternative qui se développent
et ça il faut pas je crois ce ne pas
prendre ses responsabilités s'est
défaussé par rapport à cette situation
donc nous agissons aussi en matière
d'égalité des chances et c'est pour cela
que nous avons aussi des réponses très
forte sur le cadre de vie sur
l'éducation parce que il ne s'agit pas
d'apporter que du quantitatif à
l'éducation
c'est aussi apporter du qualitatif donné
aussi l'espoir et la chance à chaque
jeune de réussir dans ces quartiers
c'est aussi donner de l'emploi
quand vous êtes face à des
discriminations dans l' embauche vous
qu'est ce que vous vous dites vous vous
dites que finalement on me rejette
je ne suis pas aimé et donc vous allez
vers quoi vers l'autre offre qui va vous
permettre finalement de toucher un
revenu et de manger et de faire vu votre
famille c'est bien ça dont il s'agit au
quotidien donc l'état revient en force
dans ces quartiers c'est ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui c'est ce que nous
avons déjà commencé à faire avec les
maisons france service en remettant du
service public
j'étais à marseille dans les quartiers
nord et quand vous visitez la maison
france service et que vous avez des
mères de familles des jeunes des jeunes
dans ces quartiers qui vous disent
heureusement que cette maison est là
parce que grâce à elle je peux avoir
accès à mes droits et ne pas être en
rupture de droits
je peux aussi avoir accès à
l'information ça c'est du retour du
service public et c'est le retour de la
promesse républicaine dans nos quartiers
donc je pense qu'il faut vraiment agir
sur les deux leviers comme a dit le
président de la république le
sécuritaire et là nous ne tremblons pas
mais également toutes les mesures en
faveur des gars étaient des chances pour
donner
à chaque concitoyen la chance de réussir
et merci beaucoup merci madame la
ministre est revenue sur ce plateau
merci fabrice a vite on va accueillir
dans quelques instants le sénateur deux
matches
[Musique]